a lot of reaction to memetic about the
fact that on the weekend he plays that
game where he's a cowboy you spent the
whole weekend in front of the TV we're
playing these video games yes it's like
a role-playing game
what was your role who were you I'm a
cowboy you ignored your girlfriend's
texts all weekend no I did not ignore
her text I told her ahead of time I'm
spending the weekend as a cowboy don't
disturb my god you can be a nice cowboy
or a bad cowboy my Matt what are you
nice I love that momentum bad boy bad
everything he's not in life
and I like that like he didn't [ __ ] his
girlfriend all weekend because he wanted
to be alone
JD being debated yeah
what's your name on the website what
does you know what's your name III just
say da VA that's it that's garbage stand
for it stands for the badass I'm a
cowboy
well it described what's the game called
it's called Red Dead Redemption too and
I bought it cuz I'm a fan of the first
game and it looked awesome but it seems
like it's like chores and things hid it
in my Mets word words you are living
like a cowboy but you're living every
single detail of what it would be like
to live back then so you have to wake up
like you said you have to chop wood you
have like pick flowers for medicine yeah
you have to take care of your horse for
10 or 15 minutes you're just living life
but wouldn't you rather spend the
weekend like going to a concert or or
even like maybe go see a real horse
there's both I will say the game I mean
the game is beautiful it you could
totally you know especially if you're
smoking something and then out and kind
of just forget about life for a while
but it's not an action-packed game in
the game you can pay a sexy woman to
give you a sponge bath want to hear that
Oh
so like once I get this character in the
bathtub
a female walks in and says would you
look that like it seems like you don't
have to do anything it's like you're
watching a movie yes at that point it
becomes a movie so the woman comes in
and they'll give you three options you
could either play nice with her you
could be mean to her or you can you know
probably rob her a killer is usually the
third option would you like someone to
take over for you good now don't you
worry about a thing I hope the water is
hot enough hanging off when I get a hot
bath and a roof over my head oh really
sounds like that dude and the cowboy
kind of sounds like Christmas arson oh
yeah so this must be the option where
you're nice to the woman no how'd you do
this weekend we how much had the game
are you through
I'm playing a different game than Jason
I swear to God what do you experience is
way different did you get a bath from a
prostitute
yes my cowboy doesn't waste time flowers
and [ __ ] like that well how do you avoid
that I just rob people all day long I
don't wait for a bank robbery right now
I'm wanted dead or alive Oh tell you
that since you're a bad cowboy when you
got your bath did you yell at the
prostitute no the prostitutes I'm nice -
Shirley told me the game sucks he tried
it he said his she plays really dumb
games though with no story yeah of
course I mean I could see a video game
where you get to actually just kill [ __ ]
and use some skill that's what I'm doing
these guys pick flowers and chop wood I
go out and I rob and I kill Shirley did
you sure he's getting big laughs in the
other room
by the way first of all I want to thank
Shirley for his service he plays Call of
Duty where he's you know he's a
military's in the mill he's at least in
the make-believe military thank you sir
the lead character is a cowboy named
Arthur Arthur Morgan yes do you ever
take your cowboy character Arthur into
bed with you like with your girlfriend
and roleplay as a bad cowboy uh no but I
mean you know maybe one day right I'm a
bad cowboy I know